martha 2,6 drague sénatrice des yvelines
et rapporteur de la loi gaspillage
économie circulaire a organisé une
réunion autour de cette loi adoptée au
sénat est examiné à l'assemblée
nationale une loi autour d'un certain
nombre de dispositifs qui concerne plus
spécifiquement les élus locaux et les
territoires en premier chef
ce sera essentiellement autour bien
évidemment des déchets et des dépôts
sauvages puisqu'on a un vrai sujet dans
notre département mais également sur
tout ce qui concerne les plastiques en
hors foyer les usages que l'on fait
selon les régions nous n'avons pas
toujours les mêmes codes couleurs pour
les poubelles le texte permettra
d'uniformiser cela un objectif partagé
il ne s'agira pas pour les collectivités
d'investir dans de nouvelles poubelles
parce que vous imaginez le coot l'idée
c'est de trouver un code qui se soit
partagée par nous tous et qui soit le
même dans toute la france
martha décidera qui est revenu sur les
bouteilles en plastique et le logo
inscrit dessus le point vers les usagers
pensent en grande majorité qui signifie
que le produit acheté recyclables ces
faux qui ne faut pas induire notre
consommateur en erreur
il faut leur donner la bonne information
et c'est le sens de deuxième logo dont
on a parlé ce matin qui est le tri man
et chivu stipule très clairement si un
produit doit être triés et donc
potentiellement recyclé derrière martha
dos idrac s'est rendu à l'usiné france
plastique de recyclage de limay où sont
reconnaissables des bouteilles de notre
usage quotidien
le recyclage des produits de
consommation courante c'est un des
volets de la loi gaspillage et co2 lui
circulaire ces plastiques vont
évidemment être introduit dans
l'installation qui est à côté de nous
qu'ils vont subir tout insiste tout un
procès ce qui de déchets plastiques tel
que nous le voyons ici vont devenir en
fait des paillettes qui vont être
incorporées dans des produits finis et
qui vont de nouveau être réinjectés dans
le commerce le but avoir une durée pour
ses produits la plus longue possible en
l'airé introduisant de nouveaux dans une
filière qui n'est pas forcément celle du
produit d'origine
le gouvernement affiche un objectif de
100 % de plastique recyclé pour 2025